protesters in favor of roe v wade have  been gathering at the homes of supreme  court justices  alito  and kavanaugh is this okay on the one  hand  is the proper venue not to form a mob at  someone's home  but to go to the supreme court or even  to go and vote locally in your state to  make sure that abortion stays legal  on the other hand when supreme court  justices are appointed for life  beyond any serious consequences for any  of their decisions even if they go  directly counter to what they said  during their confirmation hearings  what other tools do people have let me  know in the comments is it okay to  protest at the houses of supreme court  justices